good morning
Millennials welcome back to the toast
and happy Tuesday hope everybody's
having a great day speaking of choosing
and the girl I always choose your first
choice it's the ladies choice choice
choice I'm the
ladies it's Jack it's me hey L de in the
Tuesday L de in the two one two L tur
Deo on the ones and twos turo is always
on the ones and the twos so true happy
Tuesday welcome back to the toast
everybody I'm still coming down from my
Disney High and now I'm in a Disney
content high like last night Olivia and
I recorded a Disney podcast episode that
was over one hour recapping our time at
Disney answering everybody's questions I
think we got to everything like
everything that happened every thought
in my my head every question that people
had I think we covered the gamut and so
now I'm just like reliving the dis and
that's a fun place I haven't listened to
it yet cuz Jackie put it up immediately
the people needed to know what you know
the tea was so I haven't been able to
listen to it but let me tell you I've
literally never been so excited to
listen to something oh I'm so excited
for you to listen to it and actually
Zach Shapiro makes a cameo at the end
because he felt like he was
misrepresented on the toast and he
wanted to he wanted to clear his name
and so I said have him record an audio
recording speaking his truth and I'll
put it at stat he he put out a statement
at the end of the episode with his
thoughts on Disney okay that's so funny
and he called me too kind of like
feeling as though we besched his good
name on the episode of the toast and I
just want to say the fact that he
listens to the toast like obsessed yeah
everyone was kind of listening to the
toast to see what we thought about
Disney I it's such a thing Disney it's
crazy it is a thing and having put one
foot into that world it's hard to like
just toggle between two different worlds
one of a magical elk and the other
that's how Harry Potter felt and the
other of a realistic
elk um I cannot wait to listen to that
episode and what's so exciting is that
if you're a patreon member you'll
obviously be able to listen to that
recap with Olivia and Zach and Jackie
but tonight we're doing a special live
podcast episode which is something
before Jackie moved back to New York and
things got a little hectic we used to do
once a month and then we totally forgot
about it and then the other day we were
like wait remember freaking Fred our
iconic monthly live podcast on YouTube
and we're doing it again tonight so 8:00
p.m. eastern time it's not too late if
you want to become a patreon member join
live you can comment live we're all
going to be like just chilling laughing
giggling having a cocktail like it's
going to be so much fun I've missed
these live episodes and actually haven't
done one for my new apartment excting
exting I'll be here in the studio live
show it's morning toast live show at
8:00 p.m. it's evening toast live show
it's morning toast live also I'm getting
a haircut today at 6 o'clock your hair
looks like it just was cut oh thank you
it wasn't I'm like so sick of my hair
which is why I'm getting a haircut that
I've been doing I did something
different with it I was going to say
like your hair looks different so how
are you sick of it but that makes sense
it looks different because you're sick
of it I di an air wrapped which makes it
shorter I do feel like my hair is too
long that's why it looks like a little
fresh today but um it will look much
better tomorrow and I think if you want
to see the haircut like you know before
everyone else sneak peak you got to join
the YouTube live podcast for the toast
freaking Fred January episode Never Too
Late sign up at patreon.com theeast yeah
it's never too late to become a patreon
because we'll always be there and we'll
always be turning out new content but
it's time like the patreon is popping
that's where it goes down in the patreon
I feel like we're always on this show
talking about things that happened on
the patreon and if you want the whole
360 view of the toast you've got to be a
patron and you do you don't want to just
be looking at it
two-dimensionally h life is so much
better in 3D yeah that's why we wore our
3D glasses for Mickey's Phil har
magic exactly except I have to be honest
I hate 3D glasses movies like oh my God
Donald's like flying at my face throwing
pots and pans like calm down Donald calm
down Donald
he can't and also are you supposed to be
able to understand what Donald's is
saying you know how he talks like a duck
he's like you got the wrong [__] here
like I don't know sorry I'm not asking
you I'm asking the broader
audience Donald talks
like but he's saying stuff that's so
good that class Donald I think you are
supposed to understand him now I don't
think so because it's so
unintelligible so maybe
seriously like he's supposed to
represent like non-verbal there are kids
who are non-verbal like maybe that's his
that's true I want know if we're
supposed to understand Donald because if
we are like he's too difficult to
decipher and if we're not it's like well
why are we listening to nonsense right
and it's like when you do understand him
he is saying things so it's like nobody
hears Donald what about what Donald
thinks I feel like Donald is literally
in a prison of his own mind yeah but
it's also nice for him because I feel
like he gets to remove himself from
mickeey and Mickey ego and Mickey's
narcissism totally which when I watch
Mickey Mouse clubhous like it really is
becoming crazy how Mickey is Kim
Jong-un you know totally but then when
when I went to Disney I had an
appreciation for Mickey and his what I
would instead call
branding right because like let's not
forget like he was the first [__] here
he invented this whole family so let's
just yeah yes he's definitely a diva
egomaniac giving you know Victoria
Justice energy having said that I do
feel like he's earned the right right
like what he's built is incredible when
I watch the show it's it's even crazy he
built is incredible it's even crazy when
you watch the show Mickey's ears are
never like if he turns to the side his
ears are still facing the front like
he's never actually caught out where
like he always two circles facing you no
matter if he head turned any degree H I
wonder what the symbolism is there
because it's like they are going so hard
for the Mickey branding the ears the
mickeey ears they're selling ears it
works but then when you see Mickey at
Disney world like his ears aren't like
that and he's a real boy too and Mickey
has feelings too it just really
humanizes
Mickey I get it you know you really see
him in a new light yeah like Mickey has
a
[Laughter]
FAA wait am I
Mickey wait Mickey does have a FAA Loki
and those pant are super unflattering
yeah but it's
humanizing yeah and is Mickey supposed
to be like a child or a 97y old man
Mickey is an elder not 97 but I would
say Mickey is in his 30s 40s that's
weird I guess so and then also Mickey
and Minnie brother and sister or husband
and wife com so unclear it's disgusting
I think that they are husband and wife
but there's a lot of things that it
could go either way like in one of the
books that we have they have nieces and
nephews Morty and ferdy and
Millie and it's like so they could be
still the aunts and uncle from being
brother and sister or by marriage okay
no they're definitely married because
like what are the odds that Mickey and
Minnie if they're siblings they both
don't have kids oh they have another oh
yeah and where did there where do who's
are the parents who are the parents of
fori and mury and
Millie Mickey has a brother or sister he
he acts like an only child he does act
like an only child and I don't know
we're going to need a family tree stop
we are but I'm sure one exists because
the world of Disney it doesn't happen by
happen stands like everything is very
much tethered so I appreciate thoughtful
and it's like it's well thought out and
there definitely is like a Disney
Library where they have all the archives
and there's a family there's definitely
a family tree there yeah for
sure I just can't believe we're in our
like Disney we're talking about Disney
era like I never thought we would be
there I'm kind of like a hater but that
such as life like my life recently is
just talking about and enjoying things
like I used to make fun of and I just
need to get over it no every day it's
more and more with you like the person
that you are it's shocking I'm glad that
you're
aware yeah of course I'm not blind like
duh the way
2020 you would clown on 2024
you is wild but 2024 you is clowning on
2020u of course you know downt T Abby
comes to mind which reminds me that I um
attempted again last night to watch the
guilted Age season 2 and I didn't
realize I've tried already I think like
three times I am only on episode two and
it's like
unwatchable so it's not a good show but
we're so desperate for content of that
elk yeah that we all pretend like it is
and we just accept it and we all no one
wants to say to Julian fellows like you
done messed up cuz it's Julian fellows
there are a lot of things wrong with the
show
and I think the biggest one is like
Cynthia Nixon never should have been a
part of that show like she's just it's
the least believable thing on the planet
I'm sorry it's like why is Miranda Hobbs
cosplaying it's just too much yeah and
and I said this on the phone and it's
going to be a really honest and kind of
mean thing to
say there is nobody on on the show boy
or girl who's like really really really
beautiful or handsome and like they're
all just kind of like average looking
and I don't know I just want to watch a
show of beautiful people that's how I
feel that is like something that's
important to me when I watch a show and
there are some shows that come to mind
that I had obstacles getting into
because I didn't see the beauty in it
right like the the screen is for the
exceptionally beautiful right where are
they yeah especially when the story line
is about how one person is is like
captivating the town and it's like well
you have to be captivating then yeah no
and the acting is just bad and it's like
it really is giving it's so Community
Theater even the sets the set that
street 61st Street like fraudulent it's
so fraudulent I think the woman who's
cast as the new money neighbor across
the street is really one of the worst
castings like she's I really like her
character I really like her I like her
character and I like her as a actress
but not together no not one person that
I see on the screen like you could ever
ever make me believe actually is living
in that time period except weirdly Miss
Aster she's so classic yeah no it's it's
Community Theater
and I am I'm officially giving up on the
show okay maybe you should watch the
Buccaneers okay I think you would like
it because it's like old timey Vibes
with like jensy attitudes it's like
Bridgerton last night I also started to
watch maybe I was just having a night
where I couldn't get into stuff which
happens all the time I started to watch
season 2 of the Traders on peacock cuz
everybody's talking about it and mostly
I just wanted to watch it because my
girl Mercedes jaob is on there and like
she's just reality TV gold then I
realized they had some other good cast
members especi mostly from Bravo they
had um fedra also another professional
reality star tamber judge but there were
like a lot of people who I didn't know
cuz they cast from like big brother
Survivor MTV's The Challenge and so
honestly I knew less than half I would
say maybe I knew five characters and it
was uninteresting and I turned it off
and do they have any lay people on the
show no and it's weirdly hosted by Alan
Cummings and when I saw that I was like
oh he obviously just like pre-record in
a studio and then like is the host no
they filmed at this like Palace in
Scotland it was actually really sick
I've seen that and he's there like there
with them like doing the CH not like
doing the challenges but like hosting
involved I wonder why he took that gig
it's so in congruous with everything we
know about him I just feel like Alan
cuming once you think you figured him
out he goes and swerves on you
yeah I one time saw Alan [__] riding
a bike in the city and I was like oh my
God that's alen [__] I like said it
out loud because I was like having the
discovery and he was like it is Alan
[__] and then just kept driving it
was actually like so such a New York
moment classic Allen coming CAC I
imagine that was a hard last name to
grow up with he seems to have
persevered yeah who was I just having
this conversation with I forget who but
it was like talking about how
celebrities are kind of like for the
most part and I mean tradition not
influencers or models like traditional
celebrities who act or sing are for the
most part like Geeks trapped in the
bodies of extremely good-look people um
cuz when you think about it like they
really all were like theater nerds and
they were never the popular kids yeah so
you see them in interviews and they're
acting weird and everybody's like this
is weird it's really not no I think a
lot of people realize that that the
actors and actresses are the theater
kids from your class but it's weird
because you know those aren't always the
most beautiful people in the classroom
but then they all become beautiful in
Hollywood yeah it's weird how like or or
maybe that's just the Hollywood magic is
like they only select the Beau beautiful
theater Geeks right right right that's a
good point or I was going to say you
know a little money and connections can
make anyone beautiful maybe we're all
just you know ugly ducklings waiting to
bloom I'm wearing a belt and it's like
literally making me physically ill
goodbye goodbye belt hey look look at my
belt good day belt oh my God so much
better did you just want to show us your
belt no actually yes I am wearing an AES
belt but I put the H in the back like
it's not what I it wasn't the vibe today
you're not Billy ish on the toilet at
that award
show your mind is a sponge like how you
remember that actually I remember it
because I was going to wear an outfit
today and I was like have I worn this on
the toast recently and so I scrolled on
our Instagram to see if I wore it
recently and I did and while I was
scrolling I saw a title called hey look
at my belt
so your belt today reminded me of that
that I'm going to I'm going to share my
trade secrets on that one I don't have
the best memory ever also it's worth
noting that yesterday's episode like
might have been my favorite episode I I
think I've watched the whole episode
like three times I was cackling so hard
we were both being just so funny
and when it came to S now of course here
I have to correct some Jed Brock birie
is a rookie like seriously you guys shut
up like we don't care we know we're
wrong we're having fun no but the thing
is like for real like this show is for
fun so when you come in the comments
with your factchecking energy like [__]
off go do that at like CNN MSNBC like
not us we're just having fun like facts
are just not important here they're
really not eat my ass no they're really
not I just want to say like the there
weren't Corrections like I wasn't saying
Brock pie is under because of his no by
the way we didn't say Brock pie is not a
rookie like we
know so he's undera because he's early
on in the league but I will always cite
this as precedent there was a player on
the Cowboys who like just woke up one
day and decided he deserved to be paid
more I think it was no your worth I I
forget which play it was it might have
been like Ezekiel Elliott was his name
and Zach and I like would debate like
should he get more money because he was
a really good player but like the
Cowboys had gone nowhere like wait your
turn and actually Jerry paid him more
and then he continued to stink and
they've got still gone nowhere now he's
like not even on the team and so a few
years later I got to say to Zach like
told you
so good thing you're not holding on to
it no because it it really was just like
we really disagreed he really thought
that he should get paid more and I
really thought like you need to earn
your stripes and finish out your
contract but in this situation Brock Pie
has taken them to the conference
Championship now twice like even before
his contract is up he deserves more
money I know he's Jackie or a bonus yeah
I agree with you yeah but it but in that
situation I just felt like the Cowboys
hadn't done any yeah maybe that one
player was playing good but like the
team didn't go anywhere for him to like
even if block per block Brock was
playing really good but like you know
they didn't win this past game or
whatever no no raise no dice but two
conference championships in a row Jackie
Brock pie is the Jeremy Lynn of the NFL
are you familiar with Lin sanity yes for
anyone really
tall no many many years ago the Knicks
were like you know having a bad season
again and like every single player was
injured that they literally put on in
the last five minutes of a game a player
who I don't even think was suited up
like his name was Jeremy Lynn he went to
Harvard and he was probably the lowest
paid NBA player of all time and I don't
think he ever set foot on the court in
an actual game they got so desperate
they threw him on in last five minutes
this kid scored a million points that
the next game they started him and they
called it Lin sanity I think it was a
series of like 10 games where the Knicks
did not lose all because of Jeremy Lynn
now it eventually fizzled out and he's
like a decent player now and he gets
like good contracts on different teams
but the city was alive with Lin sanity
like it really ushered in this like
crazy wave of fandom and you know what
he deserved a bonus for that right yeah
I think I read he was making like
$200,000 yeah but typically I'm like you
should finish out your contract but I
also think it's a case by case situation
if you're doing incredible remarkable
things yeah you should get a bonus a
merit-based bonus who doesn't love that
yeah based on like performance
benchmarks
yes and honestly like there are a lot of
players I think on the 49ers who are
paid very well because a lot of the
players there this is what I was saying
yesterday have been on the team for like
five six seven years and like they've
put in the work and they I think have
really good salaries and you know
looking around it's not fair I
agree yeah anyway so those were the two
and Joe burrow was injured that's why
they didn't go far yeah I just like with
the the sports things it's like either
the people who comment on our Sports
commentary are girls who like watched
Sports before and they definitely feel
Territorial and they know more and
honestly they're annoying as [__] or
it's like men being like I just lost
three brain cells and it's like you
didn't even have to start with our our
Sports video from yesterday like clearly
reached people outside of the to which
is what it's designed to do and and
thank you on Tik Tok that when something
like that happens they say like it
reached the wrong side of Tik Tok no it
did I wouldn't even say it reached the
wrong side because like we're putting
out content and we're hoping that people
outside of toasters will see it that's
the best key scenario but some of those
people are kagin and kin bring their
energy to the comment
section and you just have to learn to
scroll past it they're like oh I guess
anyone could have a podcast these days
not one that millions of people watch
ugly [__] no but factually yes anyone
can have a podcast it's a beautiful
medium that has democratized having a
voice yeah no that's kind of the
beautiful part of the medium is the
Democracy of it all that anybody can
have one and the cream will
rise yeah yeah love that
Jack so yes I called us the cream or
creme as they say in Fr by the way we
are cream you are keragen that's the new
like I am Rubber and you are
glue we are cream you are kage are we
cream or are we creme we're really cream
well it depends if we're feeling French
La it depends where we are yeah which
hemisphere we're constantly moving
hemispheres
constantly like it's kind of hard to
keep up with us oh also I saw something
on Twitter that was like so not real you
know no a baseless rumor that the NFL
and Christen usechek are apparently in
talks to like be working together for
merchandise I saw that you sent me a
tweet from a rumor mill I mean I would
hope so yeah where there's smoke
hopefully there's fire that would make
sense yeah fingers
crossed so now I think without further
ad Ado yeah are we talking about the
Oscar Noms
are we talking about the ascoms we are
okay without further
ad here are the fast five stories that
you need to know and the fast five
stories that you need to know are
brought to you by Quin who doesn't love
the good things in life even though we
enjoy a little luxury that doesn't mean
we always want to be paying for it until
we discovered Quint hour now go to for
luxury Essentials at affordable prices I
just actually was watching this girl on
Tik Tok do a Quinn's try- on haul and it
made me want to place another order cuz
she had like a really cute sort of ivory
silk skirt it was very cute so Quin
offers a range of high quality items at
prices Within Reach so they offer things
like 100% Mongolian Kashmir sweaters
from $50 washable silk tops and dresses
organic cotton sweaters 14 karat gold
jewelry the best part is that all the
Quint items are priced 50 to 80% less
than similar Brands because Quin
Partners directly with top factories
they are cutting out the cost of the
middleman and passing the savings on to
you Quin only works with factories that
use safe ethical and responsible
manufacturing practices and premium prum
fabrics and finishes which we love and
at the end of the day the Quin quality
speaks for itself I have many pieces now
that have aged so well they get better
with time I have cashmir sweaters I've
got great slacks I really go to Quint
for like the Staples nothing there is
insane looking like it's all good basic
what do they call it capsule wardrobe
pieces that you need to have in your
wardrobe you could wear them a million
times a week different ways styling them
no one will know you're wearing the same
pants so give yourself the luxury that
you deserve with Quint go to quince. c/
toast for free shipping on your order
and 365 day returns that's Quin Qi
nc.com toast to get free shipping and
365 day returns quinn.com
toast today's episode oh my God excuse
me not me burping in the game time ad
classic today's
twice today's episode is they paid extra
for that by game time you should not
have to worry when to buy tickets for
your next big event game time is the
fastest and easiest way to buy tickets
for all the sports music comedy and
Theater events near you did you say
sports turty I did I did with killer
last minute deals all in pricing views
from your seats and their best price
guaranteed game time takes the guests
work out of buying tickets so game time
is the only ticketing app that gives you
complete peace of mind with your
purchase they have all in prices uh that
show your total upfront you're going to
know exactly what you're getting and
that you're getting a great deal before
you check out you can buy tickets in
seconds with literally just two Taps
they have deals on tickets right up to
the start of the event even an hour
after it starts it's the place to find
last minute seats and you can find
exclusive Flash Deals for football
basketball baseball concerts comedy
theater and more with Zone deals you'll
pick the section and game time will pick
the seats for Big Time Savings and the
game time guante means you'll always get
the best price if you find tickets in
the same section and roow for Less game
time will credit you 110% of the
difference take the guesswork out of
buying tickets with Game Time download
the game time app create an account and
use code toast for $20 off your first
purchase that's uh code toast t o s
terms of apply again create an account
redeem code toast t o a St for $20 off
there's really nothing worse than buying
a ticket and by the time you get to
check out it's almost double the price
that it was when you first saw it I like
that game time their pricing is all in
so what you see is what you're actually
going to pay download game time today
it's last minute tickets it's lowest
prices it's
guadan thank you la you're welcome our
first story The 2024 Oscar nominations
are here Barbie
Oppenheimer all the movies is among the
nominees so we'll talk about the
nominees then we'll talk about the snubs
sounds good yeah I like yeah sure best
picture the big category everything's
nominated here American fiction anatomy
of a fall Barbie The holdovers Killers
of the flower Moon Maestro Oppenheimer
past lives poor things the zone of
Interest by the way it's worth
mentioning that Oppenheimer Leed is
leading with nominations 13 nominations
followed by that Emma Stone movie poor
things which has 11 killers of the
flower moon has 10 even though Leo did
not earn best actor nomination even
though his um his opposite Lily
Gladstone got best actress and Robert
dairo got Best Supporting so it was
nominated for everything except for him
and Barbie scored eight nominations even
though Greta Gerwig was right didn't get
best director and margar Robbie didn't
get best actress I I really can't talk
about the Barbie movie because the nut
jobs come out but I just want to say I
saw the movie and I actually like I
enjoyed my time at the theater it's not
an Oscar film and so the fact that Ryan
Gosling was nominated like I'm sorry
you're kidding me like that's just not
it's not serious and so yes I understand
why people are mad like because Greta GG
not getting nominated and margar Robbie
not getting nominated like if we're
going to nominate someone from Barbie
like it should be Greta Gerwig or margar
Robbie it shouldn't be Ken but I
actually don't think the movie should be
nominated like when I put it up against
the other films yeah didn't see it so I
can't say but it seems to be a
non-serious film
that no no I wouldn't say that like and
on its face it's not serious but there's
a message like I know like I get it but
I just don't think it's of the caliber
of an Oscar film because the Oscars have
separated themselves from pretty much
every other award show they're very
cinematic they're very artsy they're
very fancy they're very high brow yeah
also Barbie commercial Barbie was
nominated for best adapted screenplay so
that is for Greta so it's not like she
was totally snubbed and marar Robbie's a
producer so if they win best pictures is
credited as a producer so her acting was
actually like really excellent yeah but
it's like you can't say Barbie was even
snubbed because it has 10 nominations so
it's like okay so it didn't get all 12
in every category like that's not a
snubbing no it's not but like the two
women responsible for it don't get
nominated but like Ryan does and his
Oscars are like so his character was so
stupid I heard so many people that he
was their favorite part of the movie not
me not for you but like
that was the consensus like Ken was so
funny that's what I that's like what I
have distilled from everything I've seen
and heard like he was I thought Margo
Robbie was funnier interesting America
Ferrera got a best supporting actress
nomination okay like I I just I really
don't agree but I really don't want to
get into the whole Barbie thing people
become so unhinged yeah no but I feel
like most of these movies got nominated
in every category it's like I don't know
I feel like Oscars also just want to
like please everyone they just don't
want to be in trouble anymore no that
was like a lot of nominees that you just
cited for Best Picture yeah then it used
to be like five what I feel like it used
to be like five or six now it sounds
like eight no this is 5
10 that is a lot yeah I guess it's like
the more we're all winners it's we're
all winners and everyone can come to the
award show but still only one has to win
so what do you think will be the movie
at the Oscars like last year was
everything everywhere all at once I
think it'll be um Oppenheimer I think so
too B thing just based on Vibes based on
Vibes and based on Vibes like the other
movies that are like just as good are
like giving poor things and killers of
the flower moon but I'm sorry Commercial
Success like has to mean something and
the way people flocked to the theaters
to see Oppenheimer the way it had such
Commercial Success like that has to play
a factor in over like an art film yeah
while also being of the Oscars elf like
I think for the Oscars Academy like
they're like great these are the kind of
movies that we like and people liked it
too Nob brainer yeah yet somehow I'm
sure they'll fumble the ball yeah yeah
now for best actress also I like how
Maestro just like became a movie that
gets nominated for all these Awards when
four people saw it no mro was a movie
that was made in order to get nominated
Bradley Cooper played this role so that
he could be nominated for an Oscar it
wasn't made like to be seen and cuz I
don't think anyone saw it no and it's so
crazy cuz like I'm the type of person
who would see it no and it's also so
crazy because it's on Netflix they
couldn't make it easier yeah no there's
something going like the Maestro thing
is weird my show feels like an art movie
that you can only go and see if you like
you go to the Angelica Sundance but it's
on Netflix no it's
weird and I feel like he's doing a lot
promo wise like he brought his daughter
to the thing which he never does and it
was like yeah there was pictures but
like nobody saw it still nobody went to
go to Netflix I don't know someone who's
seen it I haven't heard a review I
haven't heard um a
whisper it's like an industry plan sort
of movie that just gets made so that
like these people can get their Oscar
Noms Maestro is an industry plant yes it
is best actress Annette Benning niyad
Lily Gladstone killers of the flower
Moon Sandra Huer anatomy of a fall
Carrie Mulligan Maestro Emma Stone poor
things who do you think Emma Stone
yeah best actor Bradley Cooper Maestro
Coleman Domingo Rustin Paul Giamatti the
holdovers chillian Murphy Killian
Killian okay Oppenheimer Jeffrey Wright
American fiction Bradley Cooper no I'm
kidding said nobody ever Killian Killian
give it to Killian best supporting
actress first nomination for Emily Blunt
Oppenheimer Daniel oh I'm so happy for
her yeah Danielle Brooks The Color
Purple America Ferrera Barbie Jodie
Foster niyad deine Joy off the
holdovers I have no idea but I love
Danielle Brooks she was my favorite in
um AR new black I don't know I didn't
see any of these movies and I didn't see
like hype for any of these particular
performances either America Ferrera you
saw and you hyped her up did you did you
like her speech or you
didn't you're trying to get me in
trouble but I did recall saying that
like everybody was fingering themselves
to her monologue and I actually thought
her monologue was giving like Pinterest
board cringe Millennial energy
I just please spare me the comments
about Barbie movie like I don't care we
need to um hide the word Barbie from our
comment section brilliant yes they're
going to spell it with two e Barb B be
like a star for the a yeah they they
know you shouldn't have said it Jackie
sorry then they wouldn't know we won't
do it best supporting actor Sterling K
Brown American fiction Robert dairo
killers of the flower Moon Robert Downey
junor Jr Oppenheimer Ryan Gosling Barbie
Mark Ruffalo poor
things don't care you know like yeah
don't care yep Best Director I actually
I feel like you don't have to keep going
actually are there any women directors
in there I think there were three oh wow
or it's like three women directors in
the movies that were nominated for movie
of the year but actually I guess I could
look at these names these are not of the
elk of women oh wait no just seen TR
anatomy of a fall I think that's a woman
so one out of five uh and yeah yeah one
out of five so that's why Greta didn't
get it they're like we check the box
girl you're usually our box check that's
like not that Greta gwick isn't
deserving that's not what I'm saying
that's why the Oscars do it they like
have to have one you know got rid they
put two yeah yeah I was not saying that
Greta gerick only gets nominated to
check a box I was not saying that I
think it depends on the movie no she's
super talented like in all of her movies
like make waves like ladybird she was
nominated for they love like she is
worthy Little Women right oh you know
what what are the craziest thing about
me that we are not little women women
that we are huge readers who grew up in
a family of four sisters who love time
pieces and we have never read Little
Women or seen and it just came out no
and well it didn't just come out no they
just did a new version it's not like you
have to go watch a movie from the 60s no
but I would rather think it rather watch
an older one like no offense like my
little women doesn't include Timothy
sham like I feel like I just want to
read the book book and like get the pure
version I'm lowkey mad though because I
watch friends and they spoil it in
friends I feel like also that book we
just
read
beautiful for your book club and
napalitano yes where they say I'm a Joe
hell beautiful wait wait so don't spoil
anything hello beautiful a because
whatever you're think like if I think
about I know hello beautiful was kind of
like
um influenced a lot by little women like
I think the book itself and also the the
characters and they also identify with
Little Women and I feel like if I think
about it too hard I'll figure out
whatever the thing is about Little Women
I won't say it but yes in the book it
was like this cute thing all the sisters
did when they were having a bad day they
would say I'm having a blank day I
forget what sister it was yeah they're
like I'm having like a Jackie day
essentially or whoever the equivalent
was now I just want to reate one more
time I do think R GG is a good movie
director I feel like people are going to
come for me that I said she checks a box
that's not what I was saying no you said
the Oscars like to check check a box
they do and so they always like oh we're
going to get in trouble if we don't give
it to a woman so they put gr a girl she
is deserving but they never put like
more than one for sure I don't I think
you've made yourself clear okay and if
anyone like still doesn't like believe
you or understand you that's on them
great you've made it
clear then other interesting categories
would just be best original song oh yeah
the fire inside from Flamin Hot I'm just
Ken from Barbie and never went away
American Symphony uh song for my people
killers of the flower moon what was I
made for
Barbie yeah I don't know how they
evaluate like song of the year when it
comes to Oscars like do they really care
about how people you know outside of the
movie enjoyed it like the Barbie song
because that would became so popular but
maybe with their
rigorous criteria for what qualifies as
best song maybe they think a different
song that was better for the movie you
know like is it more about the movie is
it about success like I don't know but
does this mean that Ryan go wring is
singing at the
Oscars yes wow I'm just K anywhere else
i' be a 10 it's like a funny parody song
is it Oscar worthy that I don't know I
don't know but I feel like he would
wouldn't want to perform at the Oscars
like he's already no he was in the
Mickey Mouse Clubhouse kids oh that's
true what was that thing called Mickey
Mouse Clubhouse no no Mickey Mouse no
Mickey what the hell hold on Britney no
I want to come to it on my own it might
have been Mickey Mouse Clubhouse
Mickey's Kids Mickey's House it wasn't
Mickey Mouse Clubhouse Mickey Mouse Club
Mickey Mouse Club
yes Club so he definitely like has you
know stage presence that's true by the
way something we didn't talk about and
you know we're not the only ones is that
Justin Timberlake announced that he has
a new song coming out it's called
Selfish and yeah well I conducted a fun
experiment cuz I said to Claudia like we
have to see what my husband thinks to
see if Justin Timberlake still has any
fans so I recorded a video I was like by
the way babe and I sent it to Claudia
just like we were chuckling I said
Justin Timberlake has new music coming
out and he said oh I'm excited I said oh
you still like him he said yeah he's
like one of my favorites you know that
and I was like oh okay so you're going
to listen he was like yeah but did he
know that he had new music coming out or
did you break the information to him
I'll have to rewatch the video because
like if even fan of his doesn't even
know like no one cares that's what I'm
saying yeah but my husband isn't so
plugged into the music scene like he
once was it's true he's a father of two
like yeah no but he used to be like so
into like new music new albums like
always and now he just listens to like
the music that he knows and loves he
doesn't like go into new music I so feel
that by the way yeah I feel myself doing
that too new music is exhausting yeah I
feel like you get to an AGI in life like
all people do where you have your music
like you don't go out discovering new
music like you listen to the classics
yeah and that's like when you were a kid
in the car with your parents they were
listening to their Classics and now you
are in the car with your kid classic can
we listen to Luke Holmes right like in a
few years the kids are going to want to
be listening to like you know whatever
is hot Lil yachty yeah no I don't think
it'll be little yachty in a few years
it'll be like someone we don't know true
someone who's like six now
right they're Hannah
Montana yeah yeah yeah I just feel like
some of those new artists right now like
will be they'll be having their
legendary era in a few years
perhaps are you ready for our next story
what number is it two yeah oh my God
yeah yeah so sopia verar is talking
about her split from Joe manello and she
said that she didn't want to be an old
mom and that's really what it came came
down to she said my marriage broke up
because my husband was younger he wanted
to have kids and I didn't want to be an
old mom as a reminder she is 51 and he
is 47 she said I feel it's not fair to
the baby she said although she respects
those who wish to welcome children later
in life the path is just not for her
anymore I had a son at 19 who is now 32
and I'm ready to be a grandmother not a
mother I'm almost in menopause it's the
natural way of things when my son
becomes a dad let him bring the baby to
me for a while and then I'll give it
back to him and go on with my life
that's what I have to do um I don't know
if we knew that this was the case but
when we reported on their breakup I
think we we said this either we knew it
or we thought that maybe because he was
younger he wanted to have kids um so I
feel like this is so like weirdly
healthy like yeah like she's putting up
her own boundaries like having kids is
not in the cards for her anymore a
because of like biology but be she's
already a mom like that part of her life
is over um but for him it's like if it's
something that's really important to me
shouldn't have to give that up either so
this is just like a really sad scenario
cuz it wasn't like there was love lost
or cheating no just like people grow and
change and he grew into someone who
wanted kids more and more she also said
that she thought the Press was very
respectful and nice of their breakup she
said I thought they were going to invent
more things and you know how it usually
is but it wasn't bad okay good and that
what makes me happy that he has this you
know new girlfriend who's around his
same age and she's pregnant right is she
or did I make that up I'm Sor I think we
were saying like she will be she oh they
are knocking boots yeah I don't know if
yet CU I think he needs to decide if
like oh is this the mother of his
children yeah yeah yeah I mean I am
available and Sophia now wants to just
date someone who already has kids
because I don't think she wants this to
be an issue no of course this is so fair
and this is how old is Joe man Janell
47 it's like so crazy like the bi like
biologically like even if she even if
they were the same exact age 47 like
it's still not really an
option for Sophia like and I'm sure she
would feel the same way at 47 that she
does at 51 it's only four years
difference like it's just so crazy like
the difference how a man can have a baby
like whenever he just wants to like robt
Jano yeah but also the fact that she
already had a child and he didn't yes
that plays a huge Factor too maybe if
when they got together if she had never
had a child then earlier in their
relationship they would have and then
would have gotten older together true
but earlier in their relationship what
was she 47 no they've been together they
were married seven years okay so she
would have been in her early okay no she
could have done it in her early 40s yeah
yeah but it seems like she's the type of
person who's not into the idea of having
kids at a what society would say
traditionally older age that's not
something she's like four right no cuz
she said like it's not fair to the baby
yeah but also her perspective is just
from somebody who had a baby at 19 who
was really young yeah and someone who
wasn't like did the newborn age 30 years
ago doesn't want to do it again no
relatable no I think this all just like
makes sense and is sad and I hope
everyone's doing well and moving on it
does make me really sad actually like
yeah I forget who I was just having this
conversation with but it was a friend of
mine who's married and doesn't have
children and she was like when we got
married we planned to have children and
then as years went on we were both just
like less and less into it so they came
to the conclusion get together which was
like oh that's like kind of Ideal like
you know not everyone gets that this
situation sucks it's the opposite it
sucks yeah growing apart
yeah are you ready for our next story
yes Kim Kardashian becomes the
Balenciaga brand ambassador after their
campaign Scandal so she's all in with
Balenciaga again after reevaluating her
relationship with the fashion house
following its 2022 campaign Scandal of
inappropriate children posing with
inappropriate objects she is the new
brand ambassador
again I could put out read the statement
she put out that's like boring and
crappy um this [__] sucks yeah I mean
at this point I I just almost wish she
never even left cuz like this is to me
more
spineless than than just sticking it out
like sticking with your contract you
could have hid him behind the contract
like this is just like let me wait for
it to die down and it actually has not
died down I was really surprised to see
like all over my Tik Tok and stuff
people really like being not even
offended but like kind of grossed out
grossed out I don't think it's died down
I it hasn't for me like for me Blen
siaga will be forever marred by this
also because there was
no ex like responsibility accepted there
were no investigation no investigations
no one was let loose from the company
like nothing changed like this they kind
of said yeah we did that [__] it's so
true there were no sort of there was no
falling out yeah so that's like the
people who responsible for this freakery
right they're still there and working so
it's still the like so no nothing's
changed so nothing's changed for me the
last time I went shopping the sale rack
was all Balenciaga yeah I don't see
people wearing Balenciaga really in the
day to day I don't see people like when
they're doing fits like post posing on
their Instagram Val
me neither what are your thoughts on
like just a lay person who like you know
saved up to buy a Balenciaga bag many
years ago like that bag we it if you own
Balenciaga before all this you should
wear it you know and you know we can
tell what's this season and what's if
you have a Blen siaga City bag yeah you
better [__] wear it it's talk about
like so many people like for years that
bag was like the It bag so many people
like collected them and loved them paid
for them it's a great bag also those
mini bags with the bees on them like are
really cute and if you already owned one
you should wear it I do wish I had
purchased one before the strike yeah but
now they're on
sale uh also um just about people
wearing the city bag so now they put out
these campaign photos they have a few
new brand ambassadors Nicola Anne Pelt
is also one of them which to me is like
less shocking than Kim cuz I feel like
she's trying to break into the fashion
industry and it's like a side door that
no one wants to walk through how about
you no I I agree like I get I get why
although it is disappointing this isn't
a person who needs the Work N but in the
photos the new campaign photos they're
all wearing the Balenciaga City bags in
like a large size and in Kim's photo
it's like in her closet and all of the
handbags on her shelf are Balenciaga
bags but it feels like they're bringing
back the city bag and I feel like
they're trying to get in on what we're
saying which is like people will only
wear vintage blend Yaga so let's what
what's old is new again and now it looks
like we're part of the zeist no I saw
that picture of Kim with the city bag I
was like oh I guess those bags are back
and they always like had the mini ones
but they were never like their main like
recently haven't been like their main
shtick which for so many years I feel
like that's how I was like introduced to
the brand
yeah with okay that Nicola pelzing is
like is a bummer I'm not going to lie
but I agree with you like I I can I can
wrap my head around the decision- making
more than I can Kim like Kim is a person
with access unlimited access unlimited
resources unlimited respect honestly she
can get invited to any fashion show like
she is the person she always wanted to
be like this obsession with the fashion
world that she's had for a while ever
since they like dissed her and wouldn't
accept her until she was Kanye's wife
and the couch thing at the Wala it's
been a journey and I totally understand
I think a lot of it is rooted in like
insecurity and just wanting to prove
people wrong she talks about that all
the time on the show how like she cares
what people thinks and she wants to
change people's minds about her I get it
but like at some point and I also get
being the type and she gets dragged a
lot for like being a person obsessed
with success and money and
accomplishments and like stomping on
other people and other things to get
there I'm like I don't necessarily think
all the time that that's a bad thing
honestly like I I think that's a
sometimes like a really a good part of a
work ethic this is an example of like a
person taking it so far I'm like kind of
losing the plot Beyond I I have to
believe that there is a reason why she
would enter into another campaign with
them and she could literally be the face
of any brand at this point and she's
choosing this one we need to know like
she just needs to make it like what is
it just tell us and it's not money we
understand like just tell us it can't be
money like money because any brand would
pay her a ton of money and she has a ton
of money like it's not like she needs
the money so I don't think it's about
money what is it it's something that we
don't
know I also think this just kind of
further cement Kim really being in her
flop era I thought she was emerging from
it because I even for me I thought she
was too even for me like there were
things that were exciting me and now I'm
taken back to this place of like what
are you doing no and now like with the
Eros tour like winding down not in the
US anymore like you really couldn't
focus on no other celebrity could be
having a moment except for Taylor in the
last like 8 months but now that the AOS
tour is going abroad and everyone's not
every single week talking about four
different Taylor Swift stories you know
another Phoenix could rise and so I I
agree I also thought she was maybe
coming out of the Flop era but this is
really bad like for real yeah and I
think the show is coming back soon did
we see a trailer for
it or just in my dreams no we I don't
think we did well skin by Kim Bey is
coming back right right she made like a
bunch of waves recently that Tik Tock
like she was doing good work you know
and this we're Back Square
One it's so strange especially cuz she's
such I feel like she's not this the type
she's not an unprincipled person and
what what we what do we know that is
important to her her family her faith
these are things that are in congruous
with the crimes of Balenciaga
yeah
I don't know yeah no major flop yeah but
like she knew it would be so why did she
do it I need to know because there
there's something she's got her
reasons just like being held she's being
held against her will there's a
blackmail Kim set yourself free whatever
it is whatever it is it can't be
wor actually it makes you think it has
to be worse than this I don't think it
could
be huh
okay are you ready for our next story
this one's number four no no I'm not
thank you I love that you've been doing
that recently I know you get frazzled in
tizy and you kind of like lose like
you're no that's the map in the map of
the show you get lost from where we are
no I get so lost in your beautiful
storytelling that I definitely like
forget where I
am and where I am is drizzly today's
sponsor is your Jan
drunk is your January look looking dry
get some lotion get a humidifier and
better yet get drizzly the go-to app for
drink delivery with drizzly you can
compare prices across local stores to
get the best price on a huge selection
of drinks for dry January every single
time non-alcoholic wines have a look
ready-made mocktails grab a straw and
order them up beer without the alcohol
yep you can take your pick you can find
them all here in the app on your phone
that's literally in your hand it could
not be any more simpler so shop for
great deals on all your dry January
beverages or other drinks and get them
delivered to your door or you know
whatever Fort you've constructed with
out of blankets download the drizzly app
or go to drizly.com that's d r izl y.com
you must be 21 or older it's not
available in all locations and don't
forget to lotion up your elbows because
they are looking a little dry so that
drizzly app is spelled d r i z l y the
go-to app for drink delivery whether
you're doing dry January or not you
still deserve delicious drinks even if
it's dry January so they have great like
canned mocktails non-alcoholic beer you
can still enjoy party it up with drizzly
if you're not doing dry January you get
the regular stuff to drizly.com or d r i
z l y app app thank you la
app is that all oh yeah okay our next
story Elon Musk makes a private visit to
owitz burkau ahead of an anti-Semitism
Symposium that he spoke on he brought
his son X okay I'm really sorry I know
this is an important story but like how
did you just pronounce aitz owitz you
said
owitz listen not that it matters but I
feel like it's aitz aitz fine aitz
aitz
ashre anyways Elon went to aitz with X
what did I say this time oh schwitz well
now I'm feeling self-conscious no you
were just giving likeu Stalin like wait
no is Stalin German no I get confused
you know who's German Hitler yeah uh
H oh yeah our mics our mic brand is it's
and I'm sure this brand is not
affiliated with the Holocaust or Hitler
in any way but the name is h l which I
feel like is a bad name for any company
I actually don't have H because I stand
against anti-Semitism oh is yours road
yeah oh M's Hy and I can't see it
without thinking H well how could you no
also Hitler has ruined a lot of things
for me ovens like really you can't think
about I can't open an oven without
thinking about it like for real um he's
ruined the word h obviously but he's
also ruined the number nine nine he's
also ruined the word
mine uh he's ruin the word come for sure
for sure but that's like not our word
that's his word he's ruined like the
color red like he's ruined a lot of
things yeah um he also ruined g wagon he
ruined European jewelry oh of course I
mean du like I was trying to be like no
like um yeah yeah no he did ruin that um
for sure but like also the G wagon yeah
anyways back to the story at H it's a
beautiful one if that's okay La um Elon
made a private visit to aitz which is a
death camp um the biggest one from the
Holocaust where over 1 million Jews were
murdered he took his son baby x and he
was part of an EJ European
Jewish uh Association delegation that
went along with us I guess it's like uja
in Europe that's what I was thinking EJ
for sure for sure I'm sure it's a
wonderful organization but like they're
not doing a good job because like
European Jews are constantly threatened
in trouble it's so true but I do want to
say like I feel uh like a kind of
regular part of Jewish life in America
is like when you turn about 18 like you
do one of these trips there are many
organiz organizations they're called
like March of the living um we went with
our school and you like visit different
camps aitz is probably the most popular
one to visit one because it's the
biggest and two because it's really been
made into like a museum and and they
have tour guides and all most of the
buildings are are still erect and it's
so [__] freaky um and there's just
like a probably the most records from
that place because it was so big and I
feel like it should be mandatory for
everyone like you know there's an 18
like you turn 18 you go to the Army in
some countries like you should go to a
concentration camp in America yeah he um
spoke about so he spoke on this
anti-Semitism Symposium with Ben Shapiro
but he spoke about how you know he
learned about the Holocaust but it's
very different like walking it and
seeing it firsthand um he said that he's
aspirationally Jewish because um most of
his friends are Jewish he said two3 of
his friends are Jewish so he's Jewish by
association we're happy to have you Elon
that is so sweet and I think that this
is like this is real allyship yeah I
mean there's been a huge conversation a
lot of people are like clut and Jackie
why are you guys always talking about
Elon he's an anti-semite he's not an
anti-semite if you wa so wait let me
wait they had said like he responded to
this tweet so I I looked he did respond
to a tweet that was like a little like I
wouldn't have said it that way no and
overly generalized and clumsy and so
people were like Elon the [__] is up
with this tweet and he was like oh you
know what I reread it I'm sorry I
actually I don't agree with that I
shouldn't have posted it so yeah so then
you want to so a lot of people were
still calling him anti-semitic even
though he reneged on what he said so
okay but then he did you know take a
trip to Israel visit you know where the
biggest Massacre since the Holocaust
happened visited all the kibuts V met
with families has spoken so much about
anti-Semitism he just now went to Poland
to visit awit it's like can we stop now
like for real he's obviously not an
anti-semite like seriously no they can
stop calling him an anti-semite you have
to read past the headlines they also
like to cite that X the formerly Twitter
has seen a rise in anti-Semitism I mean
all social media has have you been on
Tik Tok
as we've stated already before but I
guess we have to say it again like there
are there's research and data that has
come out of like the most anti-emetic
platforms X is not number one it's not
number two no and it's like so fabulous
that everybody has all this energy for
anti-Semitism but I don't understand why
it's solely when it relates to Elon Musk
I know mus completely misguided Elon
Musk has like made himself an enemy of
like of the public because he's like a
renegade and he say not the public of
the media Elite and he like you know
does things differently and he says and
does what he wants and it's like I wish
people had all this energy for
anti-Semitism like actual anti-Semitism
as they do for Elon because the Elon one
I looked into it as a Jew I looked into
it I don't find this person who just
visit visited a schwitz birkenau to be
anti-semitic I don't so it's like okay
but let's keep that energy up for the
others no like if you have all this
energy for anti-Semitism let me show you
a few things you can Channel it towards
if you have all this energy for
anti-Semitism I've got a couple
Instagram accounts that you should look
through like they it's so insane to me
like it's like enough ready for real no
it's it's foolish but the thing is
people really fall for it because even
today you'll see in comments people
being like elon's an anti-semite and
it's like really no and we need to like
not do with do like um what's the word
uh overuse the word anti-semite because
when these I I do really believe when
like a lot of social movements happen
people get like a little uh they start
saying like well this is anti-Semitic
and that's anti-semetic and sometimes
it's not and it I don't want I don't
want the word to lose its meaning which
I think can happen in like social media
advocacy but there's no lack of
anti-Semitism for you to be speaking up
against so if you want to bring your
energy and and stand with the Jews let's
start with October 7th how about that
yeah I love that anyway someone who's at
owitz wearing a dog tag to bring the
hostages home and a yamaka and bringing
his young son so he can also see what
happened like stop stop stop like don't
be stupid like for real like let's Mo on
no yeah seriously don't be stupid no
like I understand like maybe you you
read some things and you got convinced
and like you were trapped but like now
let's look at the facts you were wrong
I'll allow it let's move on yeah and I
like to think of ourselves as like
anti-Semitism Watchdogs you know oh we
are we are the posting police you should
see this group chat we have it's like
five of us where we literally screenshot
every single thing that's posted online
that's even remotely like similar or
could be connected to anti-Semitism and
we dissect that [__] like we know who's
anti-semitic and we know who's not and
onou chat the group chat has officially
decreed Elon Musk is not an anti-i yeah
and we'll always let you know on the
show when someone's doing something or
not doing something when someone's being
accused of anti-Semitism or they're
using anti-Semitism to F like to take
someone down when it's not about the
anti further their Cause And The Watch
Dogs no call off the dogs elon's on
anti-semite in fact he's an ally I would
agree and perhaps one of the most
powerful we have so we really need to
stop yeah not we you you yeah yeah yeah
sorry it's gonna be me are you ready for
our fifth and final story oh my God
should I sing this song it's kind of
been a while and I've been hearing cries
for it and I'm not just saying that so I
can sing I swear to God sure I I'll
never stop you from singing law it
doesn't sound like you were like so
excited for me to sing No sure because
I'll never stop you from singing lot
when have I ever stopped you from
singing okay so ask me again if I'm
ready for the final story are you ready
for the fifth and story law the final
[Music]
story
story that's funny but I know someone
who is that's funny great minds yeah no
that's why we have to bring the song
back it Sparks creativity it does that's
just like I want my dinner now which
came because two Disney adults got
married and instead of paying for food
and dinner they paid for Mickey and
Minnie to come and now people are asking
like do you understand why someone could
do that yeah I want my dinner now with
such an OG inside toast joke that I
actually didn't even remember what it
was about until you just repeated it but
for anyone who's new here we had
reported on a story I believe it was the
fourth story where these two Disney
adults got married and they really
wanted like the big characters the
caricatures to make an appearance at
their wedding but their budget really
didn't a lot for it so they decided to
forgo
food and instead use that money for
Mickey and Minnie to arrive at their
wedding and like take pictures and
interact with the guests and people
online were giving their thoughts and I
thought it was nuts and I said you know
if I was a guest I want my dinner
now that's what I would say if I was a
guest now me I don't know oh so now that
you've witnessed the magic I might
starve for
Mickey but they didn't want their guest
to starve they wrote they encouraged
them please eat before kind of like Best
of Both Worlds yeah because like wedding
food's never that good so at least you
got to meet Mick there's something about
the man for sure he's got something he's
got
RZ he's got buddies he's in magazines
he's got more money than oh yeah and
that's the other thing about Mickey he's
wealthy
he's kind of like the
uh Carlile Cullen of his world he's been
around for so long he he's got stocks
since the early 1900s yeah no but he
also he has Parks he has shows yeah oh
yeah he's making moves licensing deals
you like he owns
ESPN right maybe he can give us our show
Claudia that's who we need to suck up to
oh my God he also owns like Desperate
Housewives he he's an amazing man yeah
of course he's a little crazy who isn't
right what show me a genius that
isn't our fifth and final story Rihanna
fan girls over Natalie Portman and vice
versa at Paris fashion week so at Paris
Fashion Week Rihanna and Natalie Portman
ran into one another Natalie Portman at
first fangles over Rihanna because like
who wouldn't but then Rihanna couldn't
help a fan girl over Natalie herself
ahead of the Christian dier fashion show
so gushed over Natalie just seconds
after seeing her arrive at the hot
Couture show she said you are one of the
hottest Hollywood hottest [__] in
Hollywood
Forever and she added so nice I know she
added that she's a fan of hers she said
you do the most innocent look and I'm
like ah the compliment took Natalie back
as she revealed that she in turn was a
huge fan of Rihanna she told the singer
that she might faint and black out after
hearing the compliments that's actually
really funny because when I first saw
this I was like how in the world does
Rihanna even know like Natalie Portman
but then like they really Natalie
Portman like is obviously classic
actress been around forever but she's
such a fashion it girly she's the face
of I think Dior perfume yeah thank you
oh my god [__] um and she has been for
a while she's like a Real Fashion it
girl and of course Rihanna is like so
fashiony and influential in the fashion
world so actually I do believe that
Rihanna like kind of stands but what's
so crazy is Natalie Portman one of the
most beautiful women in Hollywood etc
etc when she's standing next to Rihanna
who was just like
icon period Natalie Portman looks like
she works for she's a stage hand you
know she looks like a regular person
who's there to walk Rihanna into the
show there are certain people who have
that effect and there are also certain
people who like no matter who they're
talking to the person is going to be
freaking out and Rihanna is one of those
people Beyonce is one of those people
Taylor Swift is one of those people like
even if Taylor Swift was talking to like
you know the president like anyone would
like be on their knees it's like really
crazy and Rihanna is one of those people
too cuz cuz Natalie Portman is like
A-list for the last 20 years like she's
really in an upper echelon of Fame and
like even Rihanna like she's died but it
makes you think like as a celebrity like
even if you're aist there are people who
will humble you you know and and
thankfully for like Natalie Port me like
Rihanna was just as excited to meet her
and like that was exciting and
excitement might excite them but like
you could think your front row Dior like
my [__] don't stink but then Rihanna
walks in and it's like oh I'm not
Rihanna all so who do you think is in
that like top top tier
Rihanna Beyonce Taylor
Swift do you think there are any
men for other men like David
Beckham no I don't think D no The Rock
oh okay the rock like at one point like
Kobe Bryant was in that crew
okay but I guess the Tom Brady I I take
the rock out I take the rock out too Tom
Brady yeah the goat y LeBron put that
finger up okay but you have to add Tom
Brady I did he's five okay then LeBron
is six yeah
LeBron cuz there are people who I feel
like could have gotten to that success
and that's why I took out the rock or
like I was going to say A-Rod but like
they're both so commercial and they do
so much it's like honestly I don't even
know if I want to meet you
like took too much yeah these people are
like yeah
deity
exactly like spiritual yeah there's more
just for sure I think six is a good
place to leave sound off in the comments
who do you think else do you think is in
that upper
echelon yeah
woohoo that's our
show and I enjoyed every minute of it me
as
well that is our show thank you so much
for listening to the toast millennium
Morning Show where we deliver the fast
SI stories that you need to know every
Monday through Friday on YouTube so if
you're watching this on YouTube [__]
please feel free to like And subscribe
you know what I'm saying we're also
available as podcast anywhere podcast
can be found so Spotify iTunes Stitcher
public radio I Radio cast box all the
places we list to podcast find us toast
star you about beautiful about how
stunning and how wickedly talented we
are hope you guys have an amazing day
and we'll see you tomorrow for hump day
bye love you
bye